Salut ! Ceux qui me suivent sur les réseaux sociaux savent que dimanche dernier, j'avais rendez-vous avec le patron !
Je suis allé à Londres au 221 bis Baker Street, chez Sherlock Holmes !
Ouais mon gars !
Et à la place du générique, je vous ai mis quelques photos.
♪ Musique ♪
Tout ça m'a donné envie de vous raconter une anecdote qui m'est arrivé durant le séjour,
et peut-être que vous aurez une réponse à m'apporter à ça.
Je suis arrivé à Londres en prenant le train à la gare de St-Pancras.
Et j'étais tellement content durant le trajet que je n'ai pas réussi à me reposer,
du coup j'ai parlé avec tout le personnel de bord, et le contrôleur du train m'a raconté qu'un jour,
ils avaient vécu, avec son équipe, une synchronicité.
Une synchronicité c'est un hasard remarquable !
Ils se sont aperçus durant le trajet que 3 des passagers assis dans le train,
avaient le même nom de famille que le conducteur du train, le contrôleur et le serveur du wagon-bar.
Comme si moi je prenais le train et que le contrôleur s'appelait Olicard.
ça s'appelle un homonyme, donc sur les 3 passagers y'avait un homonyme du conducteur,
un homonyme du serveur et un homonyme du contrôleur.
Je vais pas vous donner les vrais noms de famille mais disons que dans le désordre,
ils s'appellent Winchester, Johnson et Rample.
Ce que j'ai pu savoir en discutant c'est que le passager Rample habite sur Abbey Road,
là où a été prise la fameuse photo des Beatles sur le passage piéton.
J'ai pu savoir également que le serveur habite à Camden Town.
Dans les anecdotes j'ai appris également que le passager qui s'appelait Johnson n'aime pas l'avion,
il en avait une phobie absolue.
Ah oui ! Faut savoir aussi que l'un des membres du personnel (conducteur, contrôleur ou serveur) qui s'appelle Winchester,
gagne souvent quand il joue au billard contre le contrôleur.
Et je crois pas vous avoir précisé que le passager qui s'appelle comme le serveur
habite à Notting Hill. Et en parlant du serveur, il y a une autre anecdote :
le serveur est inscrit à la même bibliothèque de quartier que le passsager qui est pilote de ligne pour British Airlines.
Et c'est vrai que dis comme ça c'est un petit peu embrouillant parce qu'avec toutes ces informations,
j'avais du mal à savoir qui était qui et surtout qui s'appelait comment.
Et quand j'ai demandé au contrôleur quel était le nom de famille du conducteur du train,
il m'a dit que j'avais assez d'informations pour pouvoir le déduire.
Alors je sais plus si ça s'est vraiment passé ou si j'ai tout inventé pour vous faire une énigme aujourd'hui,
mais ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il y a une solution logique à tout ça.
Vous pouvez trouver le nom de famille du conducteur de ce train, et c'est votre énigme !
La solution je vais vous la donner dans quelques secondes, dans la suite de cette vidéo,
donc ne regardez pas tout de suite, je suis sûr que vous pouvez trouver et revenir voir la solution ensuite,
pour voir si vous aviez bon.
Pour voir directement la fin de la vidéo sans passer par la solution, je vous mets un lien dans la description,
vous cliquez dessus et ça vous emmène à la suite et ça fait sauter la solution.
D'ici là, bonne recherche !
♪ Musique ♪
Alors, prêts à entendre la solution ?
Le conducteur du train s'appelle Winchester, comme les frangins dans Supernatural (♥),
chacun ses références !
On sait que le passager qui s'appelle Rample vit à Abber Road,
et que le serveur habite à Camden Town,
ça veut dire que le passager Rample n'est pas le pilote d'avion puisque le pilote habite dans le même quartier que le serveur.
On le sait via leur inscription commune à la bibliothèque de leur quartier.
On sait aussi que ce n'est pas le passager qui s'appelle Johnson qui est pilote d'avion,
puisque lui il a une phobie de l'avion.
Donc le pilote d'avion est forcément Winchester !
Par élimination, et ça, ça va nous servir.
Puisqu'on sait que le passager Winchester habite dans le même quartier que le serveur,
on le sait toujours grâce à la bibliothèque de quartier,
on déduit facilement que le passager Winchester habite à Candem Town.
Mais on sait aussi que le passager Rample habiter à Abbey Road,
ça veut dire encore une fois par élimination, que la passager Johnson habite à Notting Hill.
Et comme il est précisé que le passager qui porte le même nom que le serveur habite à Notting Hill,
ça veut dire que le serveur a pour nom de famille Johnson.
Mais souvenez-vous, Winchester bat souvent le contrôleur lorsqu'ils jouent au billard ensemble.
Donc déjà le contrôleur ne peut pas être Winchester, puisqu'il ne va pas se battre lui-même,
donc c'est un des 2 autres.
Et nous savons qui est le serveur, c'est Johnson, donc le contrôleur est forcément Rample.
Et de fait, le conducteur du train s'appelle bien Winchester,
Elémentaire !
Evidemment toute cette histoire est inventée de toutes pièces pour vous faire cette énigme aujourd'hui.
N'hésitez pas à en parler dans les commentaires, MAIS !
Je sais que certains vont dévoiler la solution directement dans les commentaires,
et ça c'est dommage...
Par contre je félicite déjà d'avance tous ceux qui vont se retenir de mettre la solution.
Si vous aviez trouvé la bonne réponse, vous pouvez mettre un commentaire avec le #élémentaire
et moi je saurais que vous avez trouvé, et les autres aussi.
Merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette vidéo, j'espère que ça vous aura plu !
N'hésitez pas à faire tout ce que vous voulez : liker, abonner etc...
Et rendez-vous demain à 17h,
Ciao !
♪ Générique de fin ♪